former NASA astronaut Peggy Whitson
first dreamed of going to space when she
saw Neil Armstrong take that first step
on the moon
Peggy spent a record six hundred and
sixty-five days in space more than any
other American in history she is with
Tony who's at the Kennedy Space Center
for the 50th anniversary of that Apollo
11 launch Tony hey guys she says she
doesn't make it back that much these
days but she remembers being a
nine-year-old in Ojai in Iowa on a farm
when Apollo launched take us back to
that moment
well actually the most memorable part
for me was the the touchdown and the the
first step on the moon I remember that
distinctly it was late at night for me I
was supposed to be in bed and my parents
out of bed so that we could watch it so
I think part of the reason I remember it
is because we got to stay up late to
watch you were inspired by Sally Ride
the first woman in space now there are a
lot of boys and girls watching right now
looking at you and feeling inspired
what's your best advice you've received
for them well the best advice is find
your passion work really really hard and
push yourself challenge yourself to live
outside what's comfortable for you
because that's when you're gonna find
out how much more you can really do
speaking of what's comfortable in a CBS
poll most Americans said they supported
a return to the moon but most Americans
thought the money that it would cost to
get there might be better spent
elsewhere so what's the argument for
going back well I think exploration
pushing the limits pushing our
boundaries is the reason to go back it
improves our technology here on earth
all the money that gets spent on that
space exploration is spent down here on
the ground and we're developing new
technologies so I think it's really
important and Peggy I know you happen to
believe there's more life out there
other than us do you think we'll find it
real quickly I hope so I don't maybe not
on the moon but we'll find it you're
looking for an answer on that as well
you know as we close out today I just
want to say I didn't think it was
possible to get chills in 90-degree heat
but but standing here with Peggy on this
historic day on the very spot where
Cronkite made the call 50 years ago
turns out it is possible
I feel it too because Peggy Whitson is
such a badass so lucky he's got to talk
to her